after another huge brawl and face-off
the ending of kobrakai season 5 leaves
the future of john crease's karate dojo
in enormous doubt and perhaps signals
the imminent end of the series itself
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining how cobra kai's
fifth season could be setting up a big
twist in season six plus i'll be
revealing the little details and easter
eggs you might have missed in the season
5 finale spoilers ahead of course so
take care
season 5 ends with a smashing showdown
as daniel triumphs over silver crane
kicking him through a giant glass cobra
as silver students line up to quit and
throw off their kobrakai shirts in
disgust after the revelation their
sensei bribed the referee at the all
valley tournaments in season four it
appears that kobrakai's days may truly
be numbered interestingly daniel defeats
the sneaky sensei by employing against
him the quicksilver rules that silva
taught him in karate kid 3. this is
exactly what chosen recommended to
daniel in the very first episode to
catch serpent you must think like
serpent we will use his style against
him daniel's victory here shows he's
been willing to embrace other karate
styles in addition to those he learned
from mr miyagi something he admitted to
johnny at the end of season 4 when he
saw his own daughter using some of eagle
fang's moves at the tournament but i see
some of what you teach can be good
sometimes this continues the overarching
cobra kai series theme of former foes
reconciling and then making something
new by blending their contrasting
attitudes and styles of karate together
we've combined our different styles to
train our students into the best
fighters i've ever seen by the way
notice that the way daniel lands his
final blow on silva by crane kicking him
into the glass cobra on the wall behind
him is a callback to when silva fell
into a pane of glass during the fight
with mr miyagi in the karate kid 3 as
well as to daniel's winning kick to take
out the young cobra kai star johnny in
the original movie but let's not forget
the crucial part the miyagido students
also played in taking down silva after
uncovering the incriminating footage of
tory's talk with her sensei they
remembered chosen's training and advice
to work together as a team against the
onslaught of cobra kai he said that the
snakes will take us down one by one but
what if we weren't a bunch of once the
only way we win is if we work together
similar to how together they surrounded
the basket of eggs to protect it against
chosen they formed a barrier around
anthony and the tablet which was
uploading the incriminating clip of
silva so by the end of season 5 with the
exception of crease more on him shortly
the biggest cobra kaya miyagido
rivalries appear to have been resolved
for both the og karate kid characters
and the new generation miguel and robbie
are now friends sam and tori are
reconciled and fought together against
sensei kim with devon also abandoning
cobra kai to join them oh i will be a
champion but i'll get there my way not
yours meanwhile kenny's beef with robbie
seems to have been put aside and even
stingray redeems himself when he comes
to rescue daniel what are you doing it's
pitch blackout stingray see better in
the dark but with silver hauled off by
the police what's left now for the
series and the kobrakai legacy he
repeatedly spoke about in season five i
never had any children my only legacy is
cobra guy well conveniently in season
five we're introduced to the
granddaughter of master kim who silva
invited over from korea to join him at
cobra kai i did not get on the plane for
manu what i'm offering you is legacy
your grandfather didn't teach american
soldiers the way of the fist just to use
on the battlefield we have to share his
style with the world as a child she
avidly watched the young crease and
silver train with her grandfather and
she's clearly motivated to make her own
mark in the martial arts world now silva
may be arrested but kobrakai as a dojo
was already accepted to compete at the
sekai taikai international tournament
and if she wanted she could recruit her
own students perhaps from korea and
enter the competition under the kobrakai
name thus continuing the legacy of
kobrakai fulfilling what silva predicted
cobra kai will go on forever though of
course it's also possible that she'd
want to distance herself from the bad
publicity surrounding silver and his
dojo the sekai tai kai tournament will
undoubtedly be the focus of season six
and it seems more than likely that
sensei kim will be competing there in
some form or another bringing her
grandfather's way of the fist style of
fighting to the competition and setting
up a clash with the karate styles
championed by daniel and johnny at
miyagidou and eagle fang chosen also
revealed that his uncle sato the
secondary villain from karate kid 2 had
major beef with master kim and i expect
a lot of that history will be revealed
in season six setting up a collision
between chosen and sensei kim my uncle
sato did not speak much of kim sung yang
but i know he had much anger towards him
chosen also revealed that master kim's
teachings are behind a lot of cobra
kai's brutal philosophy kim sung young
styro is based on deception no honor no
mercy of course john crease the og big
bad of the original karate kid film
we'll be back to mix things up in season
six after faking his own death yet again
the finale began with crease pretending
he was done with everything after being
tricked by his former star student
johnny an arch enemy daniel and telling
tory to look after herself from now on
and forget about him and his opening
words in the final episode this is it
end of the line a recall back to what
dany's mum said to her teen son when
they first arrived in la the event that
kicked off the whole karate kid and
kobrakai saga this is it this is the end
of the line that's a clever little
signal that although crease claims he's
giving up this moment is really just the
beginning of a new chapter in his life
just like it was for daniel all those
years ago now that an unrepentant crease
has broken out of prison it'll be
interesting to see how he reacts to
silva's arrest and discovering that the
students from his beloved dojo have
abandoned it the threat that johnny made
to wipe out kris's legacy appears to
have come true you want to know why i'm
in this fight so i can erase everything
you did every mark you left every memory
of you i expect kris might well team up
with sensei kim when he discovers she's
been at cobra kai remember from the
flashback that they both seemed to get
along with each other when they were
younger and this will be kris's
opportunity to re-establish the legacy
of kobrakai which of course came from
kim's grandfather on top of that going
up against daniel and johnny at the
international tournament will be a
chance for him to get revenge on them
for the trick they pulled on him in
prison i think kris will also be looking
to get his own personal payback on silva
for framing him for beating up stingray
first of all i'm not entirely convinced
silva will be going to jail he's got
plenty of money to pay the best lawyers
around and they could probably convince
the jury that stingray's new testimony
is unreliable given he already lied
about kris plus the video evidence of
silver beating up stingray has already
been deleted if silva does go free then
crease will likely want his own revenge
there is an endgame kick silver is going
down only he doesn't know it yet now
season six hasn't been confirmed by
netflix yet but apparently some scenes
have already been filmed however my
feeling is that it could well be the
final season of the series many major
character arcs have already been wrapped
up in season five and it's hard to see
how exactly the series could carry on
and top the stakes of the biggest karate
tournament in the world it also makes me
wonder whether there could be a big
surprise twist for the final season and
i think there's a clue in the season 5
moment when daniel and johnny were
accepted in the tournament and were
asked for the name of their dojo we just
need your dojo's name we are miyagido
and we are eagle fang well
which is it now wild and out there
theory time folks but what if johnny and
daniel decide they want to finally
rehabilitate the cobra kind name by
taking on the mantle themselves so that
miyagido and eagle fang combine to
become the new cobra kai or miyagi kobra
fang it was johnny after all who
resurrected cobra kai and it would be an
intriguing turn of events for the og
karate kid to rehabilitate the dojo of
his former nemesis he did already of
course train at silva's kobrakai in the
third movie and used some of those
techniques this season to defeat silva
the biggest problem with this idea is
that it may be hard for daniel to
justify it as fitting in with and
honoring mr miyagi's legacy of course
the whole name thing may just be a bit
of fun and a mess moment alluding to how
fans have referred to daniel and
johnny's team up in earlier seasons as
miyagi fang something also acknowledged
by stingray when he gets ambushed biaggy
things overall i feel that season 6
might be the best way to end the
kobrakai series on a relatively high
note rather than dragging things out for
many more seasons so what do you think
did you enjoy season 5 and do you think
the series is ready to wrap things up
for good in season six you can tap here
for more kobrakai videos with easter
eggs and details you missed and if you
liked this video do leave a thumbs up i
really appreciate it thanks for enjoying
cobra kai with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie loving week yippie kai
movie lovers